blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman well it's been an incredible
weekend of news uh some good some bad
some almost completely unbelievable
which we will get to
but i want to start today with an
incredible piece of reporting in rolling
stone from hunter walker
where hunter has put together
story after story
of the january six trump rioters meeting
with republicans with trump white house
staff and it is all coming together to
paint a very specific picture which is
that there were so many people involved
in this thing
and mere expulsion from the house of
representatives would not be enough but
we'll get to that we'll get to that i
don't want to get ahead of myself let's
start with the rolling stone piece
hunter walker writes
exclusive january 6 protest organizers
say they participated in quote dozens of
planning meetings with members of
congress and white house staff two
sources are communicating with house
investigators and detailed a stunning
series of allegations to rolling stone
including a promise of a blanket pardon
from the oval office this if even five
percent of this is as described this is
historic historic let's look as the
house investigation into the january 6
attacks heat up some of the planners of
the pro-trump rallies that took place in
washington dc have been communicating
with congressional investigators and
sharing new information about what
happened
when the former president's supporters
stormed the u.s capitol two of these
people have spoken to rolex rolling
stone extensively in recent weeks and
detailed explosive allegations that
multiple members of congress were
intimately involved in planning both
trump's efforts to overturn his election
loss and the january sixth events that
turned violent rolling stone separately
confirmed a third person involved in the
main january 6 rally has communicated
with the committee
this is the first report that the
committee is hearing major new
allegations from potential cooperating
witnesses while there have been prior
indications that members of congress
were involved this is also the first
account deal detailing their purported
role and its scope the two sources also
claim
they interacted with members of trump's
team including former white house chief
of staff mark meadows who they describe
as having an opportunity to prevent the
violence
look at the scope of this
the two sources both of whom have been
granted anonymity due to the ongoing
investigation describe participating in
dozens of planning briefings ahead of
the big day when trump supporters broke
into the capital as his election lost to
joe biden was being certified
here we go
i remember marjorie taylor green
specifically the organizer says i
remember talking to probably close to a
dozen other members at one point or
another or their staffs for the sake of
clarity we will refer to one of the
sources as a rally organizer and the
other as a planner rolling stone
confirmed both sources were involved in
organizing the main event aimed at
objecting to the electoral certification
which took place at the white house
ellipse on january 6. trump spoke at
that rally and encouraged his supporters
to march to the capitol
it then gets wild
along with green the conspiratorial
pro-trump republican from georgia who
took office earlier this year
the pair both say
the members who participated in these
conversations or had stopped top
staffers join include representative
paul gozer from arizona
representative lauren beaubert mo brooks
madison cawthorne andy biggs and louis
gohmert it's a who's who of the most
extreme
members of congress
we would talk to beaubert's team
cawthorne's team goes-rs team like back
to back to back to back says the
organizer
now look at this allegation
gosar one of the most prominent
defenders of the rioters allegedly took
things a step further
both sources say he dangled the
possibility of a blanket pardon
in an unrelated ongoing investigation to
encourage them to plan the protests our
impression was that it was a done deal
the organizer says that he'd spoken to
the president about it in the oval in a
meeting about pardons and that our names
came up they were working on submitting
the paperwork and getting members of the
house freedom caucus to sign on as a
show of support the organizer claims the
pair received several assurances about
the blanket pardon from goes-r
i was just going over the list of
pardons and we wanted to tell you guys
how much we appreciate all the hard work
you've been doing goes are said
according to the organizer the rally
planner describes the pardon as being
offered while quote encouraging the
staging of protests against the election
the allegation
is pardons dangled in exchange for
organizing the january 6th riots
can you imagine i would have done it
either way with or without the pardon
the organizer says i do believe in this
country but to use something like that
and put that out on the table when
someone is so desperate it's really not
good business goes office did not
respond to requests for the story
rolling stones separately obtained
documentary evidence that both sources
were in contact with gozar and bobert
they don't seem to be lying about that
part
we are not describing the nature of that
evidence to present preserve their
anonymity
um and it every paragraph every
paragraph is crazy
these specific members of congress were
involved in the pro-trump activism
around the election certification brooks
and cawthorne spoke with trump at the
ellipse on january 6th in his speech at
that event brooks who was reportedly
wearing body armor which why why do you
do that unless you suspect you might
need it declare today is the day
american patriots start taking down the
names taking down names and kicking ass
goes our green and bobert were billed as
speakers at the wild protest which took
place on january 6th at the capitol
nick dyer who is marjorie taylor green's
coms director said she was solely
involved in planning to object to the
electoral certification on the house
floor spokespeople for other members of
congress who the sources describe as
involved in the planning for protests
did not respond to requests for comment
it seems folks as if individuals here
are lawyering up and being very very
careful very very careful by the way
we have video of some of these people
admitting they were involved in planning
now they would say well we we just
planned a procedural objection it's
becoming harder and harder to believe
that that's the limit of it here's
marjorie taylor green coming up coming
out back uh in december of 2020. listen
man she's great just finished with our
meetings here at the white house this
afternoon we got had a great planning
session for our january 6 objection at
the white house
planning for january 6. now of course
she'll say but we weren't planning for
violence no we aren't going to let this
election be stolen by joe biden and the
democrats president trump won by a
landslide
call your house reps call your senators
from your states we've got to make sure
they're on board and we already have a
lot of people engaged okay stay tuned
so um this is one of the biggest
revelations about the january six riots
it's really incredible work by hunter
walker who researched and wrote this
piece for rolling stone pardons dangled
people who we already believed were
involved or admit to have been
coordinating
events that day with the white house
allegedly doing far more than that
and
it it's you know
all of these folks
are playing their roles the goes-r
pardon
never trust a promise or an intimation
from these people especially if they're
asking you to do something they wouldn't
do which gosar had no interest in going
to this thing but gosar was certainly
interested in encouraging others by
dangling a pardon which never came
trump trump told his supporters let's go
to the capitol right now he went and
then watched on tv but he said we're
going down pennsylvania avenue this
story this explosive story
was nowhere on fox news this morning
nowhere on foxnews.com maybe they'll
mention it at some point but like it
didn't even happen is their approach so
far what should the consequences be well
let's talk about what uh aoc says
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
is calling for the expulsion of
republicans involved in the planning of
the trump riot we now have as we talked
about in the last segment um the
allegations from two slash three sources
who spoke to hunter walker for rolling
stone about the involvement of marjorie
taylor green madison cawthorne lauren
bobert paul gosar louis gohmert andy
biggs uh maybe i'm forgetting one in the
planning of the january 6th protests
which turned riotous alexandria
ocasio-cortez now says anybody who's
involved should be uh kicked out of the
house of representatives kicked out of
congress newsweek reporting
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
called for the expulsion of any member
of congress who helped plan the storming
of the u.s capitol after a bombshell
report alleged that several republican
lawmakers had coordinated with rally
organizers
her comment came after a rolling stone
report published sunday night claimed
multiple members had been intimately
involved in the planning of former
president donald trump's efforts to
overturn his election loss and the
january 6 protests which culminated in
the violence at the u.s capitol she
tweeted quote any member of congress who
helped plot a terrorist attack on our
nation's capital must be expelled this
was a terror attack 138 injured almost
10 dead those responsible remain a
danger to our democracy our country and
human life in the vicinity of our
capital and beyond now i would actually
go a step further
expulsion actually isn't enough
aoc
can only deal with the expulsion part
because she's not law enforcement she's
a legislator but it actually isn't
enough
we should be talking about criminal
charges here if applicable
when the evidence points to that what i
mean is there should not be a no
criminal charges now
because these are members of congress it
needs to be looked at as if these were
any other people now realistically we're
not going to see the expulsion aoc is
right we should see it we're not going
to see it it would take a two-thirds
vote
to expel any member
this will never happen given the narrow
margins instead what probably needs to
happen
is the prosecution needs to happen and
then
that will make these folks ineligible in
theory if convicted and immediately
removed it's easier i believe to
convince i don't know if it would be six
people or if these would be 12 12 person
probably 12 person juries although it
depends on a lot a lot of particulars
it's easier to convince 12 people
off the street than it would be to
convince
highly partisan actors in the house of
representatives to vote to expel their
own to their own detriment by flipping
the balance of power further uh against
their own party so that that's just a
reality aoc completely right
we are only in stage like 0.1 in
figuring out what the fallout and what
the repercussions are going to be from
these incredible allegations based on
this rolling stone piece by hunter
walker but aoc completely right
law enforcement and the justice system
needs to be ready to go as well these
people deserve to go down for this and
one of the real problems that makes me
worried there's likely to be more of
this the next time they don't like an
election result is that there have not
been serious consequences yes we started
to see some verdicts and okay there are
people who are going to have to do a few
years
but
for the political figures involved
no consequences whatsoever and we're
going to now see if this will push
things over the edge we know that this
congressional committee has been
investigating and looking at this
evidence but is law enforcement looking
at it is the department of justice
looking at it joe biden shouldn't get
involved the way he hasn't but it should
be looked at we're going to follow it
let me know your thoughts about all of
this
via twitter where you can find me at
dpakman on twitter
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2.
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
all right i am going to talk about the
absolutely horrifying situation
involving the actor alec baldwin who
accidentally shot someone to death on
the set of the film rust it's it's
almost an inconceivable headline actor
alec baldwin
shot someone to death and injured
another person with a gun on the set of
a movie
but that's what's happened and over the
weekend we've gotten i guess i would
like to say some more clarity although
it's still not exactly clear what
happened down to the detail but we have
increasingly a general understanding of
it so let's look at the latest report
from the associated press an assistant
director unwittingly handed alec baldwin
a loaded weapon and told him it was safe
to use in the moments before the actor
fatally shot a cinematographer
cold gun the assistant director
announced according to a search warrant
filed in a santa fe court instead the
gun was loaded with live rounds and when
baldwin pulled the trigger thursday on
the set of a western he killed
cinematographer helena hutchins
director joel souza standing behind her
was wounded
the santa fe county sheriff's office
obtained the warrant friday so
investigators could document the scene
at the ranch outside santa fe where the
shooting took place they sought to
examine baldwin's bloodstained costume
for the film rust as well as the weapon
that was fired other prop guns
ammunition and footage that might exist
the gun was one of three that the film's
armorer hannah gutierrez had set on a
cart outside the wooden structure where
a scene was being acted assistant
director dave halls grabbed the gun from
the cart
brought it inside to baldwin unaware it
was loaded with live rounds
it was unclear how many rounds were
fired gutierrez removed a shell casing
from the gun after the shooting and she
turned the weapon over to police when
they arrived
halls did not immediately return phone
and email messages the ap was unable to
contact gutierrez several messages sent
to production companies were not
immediately returned
the film's script supervisor mimi
mitchell said she was standing next to
hutchins when she was shot i ran out and
called 9-1-1 and said bring everybody
send to everybody this woman is gone at
the beginning of her career
mitchell said she and other crew members
were attending a private memorial
service baldwin described the killing as
a tragic accident there are no words to
convey my shock and sadness regarding
the tragic accident that took the life
of helena hutchins a wife mother and
deeply admired colleague of ours i am
fully cooperating with the police
investigation my heart is broken for her
husband their son and all who knew and
loved helena no charges immediately
filed um i know that the new york post
for example
which is a fox you know news corporation
slash fox news publication has been
talking about manslaughter charges
against um uh baldwin if you look at the
article it's sort of like based on what
one legal expert theorizes it's
speculative
uh we we just don't know about that at
this point in time the question that's
not been answered is
why were there any live rounds on the
set
and initially there was the belief that
there was a blank and you can you can
hurt someone with a blank if you're
right next to them that this was a blank
and a tragedy an accident involving a
blank now we've learned at least it's
being said it was a live round and so
then the question is why were there live
rounds there there may be some
explanation uh but we have not yet
gotten an answer another article from
cnn
rust director told authorities alec
baldwin was practicing drawing his gun
when the weapon discharged the shot that
killed the cinematographer on a new
mexico film set last week was fired as
actor alec baldwin was practicing
drawing his gun according to the
director who was injured in the shooting
um
listen i know that
there are people who because alec
baldwin
is a left winger
and played trump on saturday night live
and there's a lot of right wing people
angry they just hate alec baldwin
they are saying alec baldwin has
committed a crime or or is to blame here
now
you can slice and dice this a lot of
different ways like for example there
was one argument that that went like
that i'm going to give you the argument
this is not my argument and it was alec
baldwin is ultimately to blame because
uh even if someone else made a mistake
by putting a live round in a gun
uh even if someone else made a mistake
by
handing alec baldwin a hot gun and
saying it's a cold gun
alec baldwin shouldn't even have had his
finger on the trigger like what if
you're on set and your practice you just
never put your finger on the trigger
period so ultimately it's alec baldwin's
fault
it strikes me as a bit of a stretch if
an investigation reveals alec baldwin
should be charged with something i'm not
going to get in the way believe me
but my instinct is
why was there a live round at all
and if there was why was alec baldwin
given a gun allegedly and told that it
was a cold gun not a hot gun that's my
initial reaction now in terms of what
this does to alec baldwin now
psychologically for the rest of his life
i can't even imagine i'm not saying he's
the victim i'm not calling him a victim
but if he was given a gun and told this
is a cold gun and it has a live round
and then now you've killed someone it's
i mean just it's it's impossible to even
think about it's impossible to even even
conceive of uh and so there's going to
be an investigation at some point we
will know more
we've already seen in the first few days
oh it was could have been a blank it was
an accident with a blank no it was a
live round at one point both stories
were were out um there's going to be
more information coming and and we'll
wait and see what that is but just a
horrifying situation and a tragedy
because someone was killed and someone
was injured it would be bad enough if
there was just an accident with a gun on
a set
um this is now beyond that and it's it's
a tragic accident as life was lost and
i'm curious to hear what folks in the
audience think and i per
for me
alec baldwin's politics played no role
in my assessment of this whatsoever just
just none whatsoever curious to hear
from you
uh we got a call from a viewer last week
who brought up china
and a discussion of the portrayal of
china in american media
and during that conversation during that
phone call we talked about xenophobia
towards asian americans over covid we
talked about intellectual property theft
and a few other topics and i got a very
good email from thomas over the weekend
and thomas said to me you know david
um there is a china story to talk about
but it's not really what the caller
brought up intellectual property theft
it's an issue it's not the major
geopolitical issue with china
there's no real evidence that china
intentionally released covet as a bio
weapon so that's not really like the big
story with china yes xenophobia against
asian americans for real or perceived
misdeeds by china is something we should
be against we're not going to be
xenophobic against asian americans
because of something the chinese
government did that that's happening and
that's bad
but thomas wrote there are real issues
with the chinese communist party now
that's another issue to clarify
the ccp and china
as in chinese people are two different
things we're really talking about the
chinese government the chinese communist
party and as thomas wrote to me
there's a ton of negativity towards
china in general that's very surface
level some of it is based in plain old
bigotry some of it is peddled by u.s
media but there are many real reasons to
be at odds with the actions of the
chinese communist party so let's look at
the real concerns with the chinese
government the ccp
and these are not reasons to go to war
with china caveat i'm not suggesting war
i know that there's people possibly on
the revolutionary left who will see this
segment and say i'm calling for another
american military intervention no the
i'm not even saying these are reasons to
no longer trade with china if we stop
trading with china would be disastrous
for the american economy as it's
currently set up we're just going to
talk about issues with the chinese
government first
the ongoing uyghur genocide uyghurs are
a muslim ethnic minority in china china
has been credibly accused of committing
crimes against humanity possibly
genocide against the uyghur population
and other mostly muslim ethnic groups in
the northwest region of xinjiang
leading human rights groups including
amnesty and human rights watch have put
out reports accusing china of crimes
against humanity for their actions there
are re-education camps there are
horrifying things and much has been
written about it that's a real
substantive issue with the chinese
government second organ harvesting this
is all
the if you put a positive spin on it
this is oh
we get organ donations from prisoners
who have died of natural causes that's
the story that china would tell
but a tribunal ruled in 2020 that china
is forcibly harvesting organs from
prisoners prisoners who certainly didn't
volunteer to donate organs but it goes
even further possibly even prisoners who
are killed for organs not who have died
naturally
the number of transplant centers in
china has gone up over 300 percent wait
times for organs have come down
dramatically it's not clear why china
doesn't have much in terms of an
organized organ donation program how is
it happens how has it happened it seems
this is a likely explanation and it is
absolutely horrifying
note that back in 2012
a top chinese official said china is
going to phase out the practice of
taking organs from prisoners who have
been executed as of 2020 we believe that
that's still going on even if it's not
aside from executed there's a lot of
other ways that you can accelerate the
process of obtaining organs from
prisoners it seems that that's being
done absolutely horrifying number three
china so poorly mismanages its own
infrastructure
that it likely has led to hundreds or
more chinese people it's hard to get
real numbers from the ccp to die due to
flooding and the idea here is that yes
there have been heavy rainstorms that
are not man-made right humans didn't
make the rainstorms but there are
serious allegations that the deaths are
a result of this infrastructure madness
craze in china where money is poured
into projects that look good
sometimes generate returns for people
but meanwhile simple infrastructure that
could be improved to prevent senseless
death from heavy rains and people
drowning are ignored okay complete
mismanagement that's a real criticism of
what's being done and then such
corruption from the ccp that causes all
sorts of problems massive fraud
embezzlement around these half-finished
villages where people make a ton of
money the projects are abandoned after
the contracts and the cash are handed
out as well as reconstruction projects
that never really happen although many
people get rich from them and then
lastly and this is a really big deal
a china's continued aggressive posturing
towards india taiwan and the south and
east china seas more generally each of
which we've talked about a little bit in
the past so on india there have been
somewhere between four and ten
skirmishes of note between india and
china over the border various face-offs
we've talked about it a little bit on
the bonus show before
the situation in the south china sea
involving china the philippines and
vietnam where you see military activity
by china naval maneuvers other
aggression outposts being built
concerning and then also conflicts with
japan and the east china sea
other part of the sea it include
it includes japan having scrambled jets
in the past and other uh escalations so
to be clear again i want to be really
careful
i don't want war with china i'm not
saying invade china i'm not saying the
us doesn't also do bad things lots of
countries exhibit this type of
aggression
the difference is number one a lot of
the criticisms of china in the u.s media
and from you know people like trump have
been very surface level and lead to
xenophobia against asian americans which
has no place whatsoever there are actual
horrible things being done by the
chinese government many countries that
also want to do horrible things don't
have both the aggression and the the
means to carry it out the financial
resources at their disposal the massive
population that china has bigotry
against asian americans because of this
or chinese people anywhere is wrong and
we're against it
i'm also not saying cut off china from
an economic standpoint our economy is
now too inter intertwined with china's
it would take a really long time to be
able to unentangle that relationship
without destroying the american economy
so i'm not calling for that but there
are real geopolitical issues here and
humanitarian issues about which we
should be concerned it's not bigotry to
talk about that and the american media
rarely touches these actual issues
let me know what you think we'll have
more on this story on the david pakman
show instagram which you can find at
david pakman's show on instagram
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount
all joinpakman.com so i i know that by
doing this story i'm gonna get a whole
rash of trolls from the left saying oh
my god david how can you praise barack
obama he's a centrist neo-liberal he's
terrible his drone policy his
deportations and of course i've
criticized all of those things but that
doesn't mean that we can't look at
barack obama speaking at a rally and
realize
wow the political discourse has really
collapsed over the last five years in
particular as the virus of trumpism has
degraded in course in political dialogue
we can't say wow
that's actually a uniquely talented
political speaker barack obama doesn't
mean we liked what he did with drones or
surveillance
so let's get to it and please don't read
into this segment more than what i'm
actually saying there's a bunch of
important elections next tuesday
november 2nd i'm going to be covering
results live with you on youtube twitch
and facebook starting around 8 pm
eastern on tuesday next tuesday night
one of those races is the virginia
gubernatorial election
now in this race
uh incumbent democratic governor ralph
northam is term limited out
so it's a race between two challengers
it's democratic candidate terry
mcauliffe
and absolutely
dangerous right-wing republican glenn
younkin
yankin is a real lunatic i mean a true
political and cultural extremist yunkan
has made clear his allegiance to donald
trump and trumpism initially although
he's since kind of backed away because
it seems like maybe it's not going to
help him that much yunkan for months
didn't even acknowledge that joe biden
legitimately won the 2020 election it's
it's that crazy of a guy he's against
abortion and he's against gun safety
measures he's really really horrible the
race is tight it's within the margin of
error i could show you polls oh 1.2
points doesn't matter it's within the
margin of error it could go either way
so former president barack obama has
been out campaigning with terry
mcauliffe and in a very specific sense
it was really refreshing
not because i like barack obama's drone
policy or whatever
but because barack obama was able to do
something
that often gets lost when we're in the
day-to-day of the current right-wing
insanity and extremism and it's one
crazy thing after another which is
barack obama distilled
just how absurd the modern republican
party and american right wing has gotten
so let's look at some clips in this
first one this is like a classic obama
thing where he hits a bunch of issues
about the hypocrisy of glenn younkin
and he touches on opportunism
and other things he starts with some
jokes and builds into hey guys this is
really serious this is this is like a
textbook two minute political speech
excerpt and you really it really it's
interesting to look at it and see yeah
the guy
the guy can hope that's great
i'm less convinced
that
the co-ceo on the largest private equity
firms in the world spends his time
washing dishes and going grocery
shopping but who knows maybe
but
yeah i mean
you do notice that like whenever
a wealthy person runs for office they
already always want to show you what a
regular guy they are
so he starts with the jokes and i know
people are saying well obama's rich to
yeah right this is political speech this
is about what are the policies and and
making a connection to that yes obama's
also incredibly wealthy
but that's okay
[Music]
but when your supporters hold a
rally where they pledge allegiance to a
flag that was flown
at the insurrection
at the capitol on january 6th so he's
doing two things here he's starting to
shift from the jokes to the serious and
he's slowing down the speed and then at
the end he'll build back up but instead
of with jokes with anger that he wants
the crowd to feel with him it's it's
it's really textbook
hey the the biggest threat
to our democracy
in my lifetime
when you don't separate yourselves from
them when you when you don't think
that's a problem
well you know what
that's a problem
you you you can't run ads telling me
you're a
regular old hoops playing dishwashing
fleece-wearing guy
but quietly cultivate support
from those who seek to tear down our
democracy
either he actually believes
in the same conspiracy theories that
resulted in a mob or
he doesn't believe it
but he's willing to go along with it
to say or do anything
to get elected
and maybe that's worse
because because
because that says something about
character
and then now here's the final character
will end up showing
when you actually are in office
what are you willing to stand up for
when are you willing to say no
to your own supporters when are you
willing to say there's some things that
are more important than getting elected
and maybe american democracy is one of
those things
so that that is really well done
political speech you don't have to love
barack obama's politics or whatever
this is a really great technique of
starting with jokes and chuckles
and then you slow down and you start to
get serious and then once you have the
audience with you you then build up to
exactly how barack obama finishes that
into getting people to feel about glenn
younkin the way they should i mean we
should be outraged about this disgusting
guy this is a really notable skill that
barack obama has and whatever your
thoughts are about him we have to
recognize being really good at something
and that two-minute clip is such an
example
of someone that is really at the top of
their field in being able to deliver
this kind of speech in this i'm going to
do one more clip here um in this clip
very concisely characterizing the
right-wing culture war as a phony
trumped up culture war designed to
create outrage i like this just because
it's a great assessment of what we've
been saying for a long time they just
they're not doing policy they're just
trying to get people fired up with these
cultural issues we don't have time
to be
wasting
on these phony trumped up culture wars
this fake outrage
that right-wing media has peddled to
juice their ratings and the fact that
he's willing to go along with it instead
of talking about serious problems that
actually affect serious people
that's a shame
that's not what this election is about
that's not what you need virginia
instead of forcing our communities to
cut back at a time when we're just
starting to recover we should be doing
more to support people who are educating
our kids and keeping our neighborhoods
safe so you guys get it a very very
highly skilled political orator his
drone program was horrible the
surveillance was horrible i'm with you
i'm with you but uh glad to see him out
campaigning for terry mcauliffe that
this i would say this is the biggest
race on the ballot uh next tuesday if
you live in virginia uh make sure you're
getting out and voting the difference
between terry mcauliffe and admittedly
establishment democrat no doubt about it
versus glenn younkin i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly
could not be more different and we're
going to have live results for you eight
days from today i hope you'll join me 8
p.m eastern eight days from today with
results i want to play for you an
incredible clip this is this is i i just
love this this is so good
there is an activist and student at
dartmouth college named i hope i'm
pronouncing his last name correctly jack
cocharella
he
went to an event with radical extremist
republican congressman madison cawthorne
who continues to claim that donald trump
actually won the election in 2020
and our friend jack confronted madison
and it's really hero's work this was at
dartmouth
cothorn is reduced to a stammering mess
unable to put together a coherent
explanation to defend his position let's
go right to the video this is really
really good
so i just had a quick question for you
uh congressman cawthorne a majority of
republicans believe that president biden
was not lawfully elected
now you know that he was and that he won
the 2020 election so when will you stop
lying your constituents admit that
donald trump lost and end this senseless
attack on our democracy so first of all
it's it's a loaded framing of the
question but for the format for what
jack's trying to do
it's absolutely perfect
[Music]
on the facts that president biden was
lawfully elected absolutely well let me
go into it right quickly there's an
unconstitutional election
absolutely go ahead okay so as you can
all see in article 2 section 3 of the
constitution the only people who have a
right to change election law in the
united states of america are the state
legislatures you saw in six key states
namely wisconsin and arizona as the
worst perpetrators the state uh policy
the state governors and
now he's wait hold on who was it that
did the legal thing that of course does
not mean that donald trump
who is was it the governor's who
i don't know no yeah trump definitely
won board of elections there who
actually went around the wheel of the
state
legislature
wait a second so was it the will of the
people or was it the will of the state
legend who what was violated exactly
madison changed election laws on their
own that is unconstitutional when you
have voter drop boxes that are set up in
parks when you can get rid of signature
verification and voter identification
laws that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this kid's got upper management written
all over them jack coacharella
really really well done and of course
the stuff that madison cawthorne is
saying we've heard it so many times
before and it's sort of a gish gallop
when you throw it all together well
there were it was against the
constitution
the u.s constitution and the states
changed the rules and it wasn't the will
of the people but it wasn't the will of
the legislatures but actually it was the
legislatures who changed and when you
put a drop box in a park or change the
magic
hold on a second
how does this mean trump won
let's look at these issues one by one by
one and listen this corn
he has his talking points prepared right
he's been he's been perpetrating this
lie
and and um perpetuating the talking
points for a while now so he knows the
talking points but in a format where you
can really take them one by one and pick
them apart you see that there's nothing
there every single one of these liars
should be questioned and they should be
facing exactly these questions
every time they appear in public
explain exactly
how it is that trump won number two
explain exactly how you talk about the
constitution in terms of the election
but you never mentioned the
anti-constitutional attempt by the
january six writers to stop the
certification are you for or against
that ex explain it it should become
impossible for these people
to evade these questions every time
they're in public uh and a really really
great job there by jack cocharella a
generation z activist and student at
dartmouth college
and uh my my guess is we'll be hearing
more from him
and hopefully i mean at every town hall
at every opportunity these people should
be asked these questions you've got to
be prepared you've got to be prepared
with rebuttals because they're going to
have some rebuttals but really really
nice job we're going to take a quick
break and we'll be back after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow okay this is
really great for weeks now i've been
reminding you every time we talk about
fox news criticizing various vaccine
requirements at different companies i've
been reminding you fox news has a
stricter vaccine mandate than the one
that joe biden has proposed for
companies with a hundred or more
employees as we watched tucker carlson
and laura ingram and dan bongino
criticized the requirements outlined by
joe biden
that all sorts of different companies
have adopted sports teams
airlines other organizations fox news
hosts would not mention hey our mandate
here at fox is even stricter
joe biden said get vaccinated or test
weekly fox news is doing get vaccinated
or test daily and wear a mask around
other employees if you're not vaccinated
fox news host wouldn't mention it they
would just talk about vaccine mandates
it's terrible they wouldn't mention by
the way where we work it's even stricter
last week during his cnn town hall which
we covered live joe biden actually
brought this up joe biden actually said
hey you know uh
there's the cynical hypocritical fox
coverage of vaccination
they have a mandate okay so take a look
at joe biden mentioning that you know
what i find fascinating
i turn on fox to find out how popular i
am
but
how are you doing there i'm doing very
well i think i'm at three percent
favorable but
but all kidding aside one of the things
i find you realize they mandate
vaccinations
at fox headquarters yeah
i find that mildly fascinating
mildly mildly fascinating
now that is absolutely true
they mandate with the option of testing
out just like joe biden proposed except
at fox if you want to test out you've
got to test daily instead of weekly
this now
pushed fox news into needing to comment
on it they can't just pretend it's not
going on and their reaction is just to
lie and play a meaningless semantic game
that is completely bogus so take a look
at what the fox and friends crew said
the next morning about their own mandate
after you misinformation he said about
fox he thought it was says i think it's
funny that fox has a vaccine mandate you
have a testing option at fox so what he
said is totally inaccurate we don't have
a mandate we have a protocol right
that's a little different so what you
tell the president we don't have a
mandate here
says steve ducey we have
a protocol why
because you can test instead of getting
vaccinated but that's exactly what joe
biden proposed joe biden said vaccinate
or test weekly and fox says vaccinate or
test daily and wear a mask
and here's why
it's not a mandate but it's a protocol
is so silly just look at what the words
mean a mandate is an official order or
commission to do something well joe
biden's order is you vaccinator test
weekly so by that definition it's a
mandate fox news's order is vaccinator
test daily that's a mandate by this
definition it's a mandate now a protocol
is the accepted or established code of
procedure or behavior in a group
organization or situation okay so let's
look at protocol
joe biden's established code of
procedure
is that you vaccinate or you test weekly
it's a protocol
fox news's established code of procedure
is you vaccinate or you test daily it's
a protocol they are both mandates of a
particular protocol this is meaningless
semantic trash and i tweeted about this
over the weekend i said so apparently
biden's required vaccine or required
weekly testing is a mandate
but fox news's required vaccine or
required daily testing is a protocol and
i received a ton of really great
responses
but one twitter user diddytrek1
lays it out the way that i did here
saying a protocol and a mandate are
synonymous
both mean something has to happen policy
is also synonymous with mandate and
protocol and that is exactly correct so
this shouldn't surprise us these are
just hypocrites these are people who
mostly want to keep their jobs even as
dan bongino
was saying
i make what dan bongino's thing with um
i think it was cumulus radio networks
although maybe he has a show on fox and
a show with a radio network it might be
cumulus he was saying listen i'm
vaccinated but i'm against any vaccine
requirements so i may quit my job here
depending on what happens he hasn't
mentioned the fact that he's also an
employee at fox which has one of the
strictest requirements now there are
some employers that have gone further
and they've said we just don't want to
deal with the testing
um or we don't want to offer a testing
option we just want everybody vaccinated
that's it and certainly that's their
prerogative and something they can
legally do
that's not actually what joe biden
proposed for companies of 100 or more
employees and what fox news has gone out
of its way to do is something that's
even stricter i have a friend who
recently started work at a um
at a west coast west coast based startup
and
during the hiring process
even right there when you apply it says
everybody on our staff has to be fully
vaccinated this allows us to do
in-person events where we can we just
test everybody on the way in and and
we've got these two layers everybody's
vaccinated and tested we can do stuff
and they do do things just don't apply
if you're not willing if you're not
willing to be fully vaccinated by the
time you start just don't apply and much
like hey this job requires you to work
two overnights a week oh i don't want
that i'm not going to apply fine you're
being you're told up front
that is something companies can
certainly do but that's not even what's
actually being discussed when we talk
about the joe biden requirements so it's
great that joe biden mentioning it
during the town hall thursday
pushed fox hosts to start talking about
it their reaction is so bogus their
explanation is so pathetic and and and
some man it's semantics at the end
um it shouldn't really surprise us and
we'll see my guess is that there's going
to be more commentary on this from them
um we have now as predicted
another new
goal post another new deadline
from my pillow ceo and founder mike
lindell
we call him mike pillow the latest is
the tuesday or the wednesday
before thanksgiving so last month our
friend zach patrizo from salon
wrote this article
mike lindell moves the reinstatement
goal posts again
now trump will be back by thanksgiving
that is locked in stone everybody says
my pillow guy despite no evidence no
paperwork and no legal case
pillow executive turned election truther
lindell has revised his prediction yet
again
as to when the u.s supreme court will
hear his undisclosed legal argument that
the 2020 election should be overturned
lindell made an excited announcement
that his mysterious legal team has
fast-tracked internal research claiming
that his thus far imaginary supreme
court case is now ahead of schedule this
is last month remember this is the big
announcement everyone he said to steve
bannon i made a promise to this country
that with all the evidence i have that
we would get it to the supreme court and
i predicted they would vote 9-0 to look
at the evidence he then asserted that
before thanksgiving which falls on
november 25 the court will have heard
his case or now
he he admits originally i hoped for
august and september i asked all the
lawyers yesterday we're taking this to
the supreme court before thanksgiving
okay
there is now a new clip of pillow
talking to mike lindell just a few days
ago
it's now
still before thanksgiving
but it's only now going to be
that an attorney general will be
supporting this going to the supreme
court by thanksgiving so it's another
backtracking first it was
by thanksgiving the supreme court will
have voted to take the case and hear the
evidence now it's i'll have an ag
supporting me by
i guess it's the tuesday or the
wednesday before thanksgiving take a
listen to this
tuesday
before thanksgiving you're gonna have an
ag that's prepared to go you're gonna
have the lawsuit filed and then you're
gonna start that evening or the next day
a marathon of information on frank's
speech
wednesday night wednesday night before
thanksgiving tuesday
isn't it is this sad or is it funny or
is it stupid or or is it all of the
above remember
after
the november of 2020 it's a year ago
guys it's a year ago at this point it'll
be more than a year by the time
thanksgiving comes around
if we survive long enough to make it to
thanksgiving uh first it was guys
between today when it was november
between today november 8th i think it
was when the media called it for joe
biden between today november 8th and
december 14th the day that the electors
certify in each state
this is going to be flipped to trump or
trump as some of them would say
didn't happen okay
between today december 14th and january
6th when congress counts the votes this
is going to be flipped to trump they're
going to stop the counting on january
6th we know how that turned out
uh riotous coup insurrection attempt in
washington dc 400 people arrested
roughly 300 400 something like that okay
it didn't go well fine between january 7
and january was it 20th or 21st that was
the um that was inauguration day now i
actually don't remember let me look at
my january calendar
it was the
20th okay
between the riot and inauguration day
it's gonna go to biden
didn't happen okay well then they
started to fork they some said all right
it's gonna be between january 20th and
march or april others said we succeeded
it's not the real joe biden that became
president it's
the real joe biden's dead
it started to get even crazier and then
you know april became early summer and
then it became fourth of july and then
it became august and then it became the
fall and now it's going to be
thanksgiving but not really thanksgiving
there will be support from the attorney
general for the supreme court case and
the supreme court case will come at some
point thereafter
what i said in november is expect this
to keep going and going and going until
at a certain point it becomes listen
guys the way to really do this
is going to be by winning the midterms
if we win the midterms then we'll put
donald trump back in
and then even if they win the midterms
trump's not coming back in so then it'll
be well now that we've won the midterms
let's just elect donald trump in 2024
that's the sequence and there's going to
be grifting
and trying to grab cash throughout the
entire thing candidates trying to grab
cash by saying give me money to win to
then bring trump back or to finally
they'll speak in coded language to
really deal with the the stolen election
once and for all
but eventually it's just going to be oh
the way to get trump back in is to elect
him in 2024 which we have been saying
all along we knew all along that that
would be the case so no surprise here
mike pillow as pathetic as ever
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192
david p
this is really funny someone called in
about on a live stream a couple months
ago i recommended a particular ice cream
this is a fantastic ice cream it's a the
brand is called it's either gratins or
graters let me actually see i want to
get it right
is it greyton's ice cream greyton's
ice this is not a sponsor
graters okay graeter's ice cream i've
been a lifelong cherry garcia fan
but i don't think it's actually that
great i just didn't know of other cherry
ice creams
greyton's black cherry chocolate chunk
ice cream maybe the best ice cream i've
ever had i mentioned it on the show all
sorts of people now are obsessed with
this ice cream take a listen to this
hi david i've been a member for
oh my god over a year but i want to tell
you
i tried on your recommendation
graters black cherry ice cream and it's
excellent it beats cherry garcia out of
the water absolutely beat something out
of the water thanks for everything you
do i appreciate your time your
um
and everything that you do for us i
appreciate it take care yesterday i
tried to get myself some of this
graeter's black cherry chocolate chip
ice cream
um
it's the one flavor that was gone from
the grater's shelf i went to my grocery
store
and i went and i said sir where is the
where's the ice cream they said here it
is sir and there's a there was graters
and they had black raspberry and they
had vanilla and then i just see an empty
space and i look at the tag and it says
black cherry
the black cherry
is sold out i'm not taking
responsibility for this i i think i
stumbled upon this as many other people
were stumbling upon it as well
uh but i can't get my hands on the black
cherry ice cream so in the future i'm
not going to be mentioning any products
that i'm interested in buying because it
doesn't seem to be going super well in
terms of my ability to get them but
fantastic ice cream not a sponsor just
good ice cream and i think like a dozen
people have told me david this this ice
cream is amazing we've got a great bonus
show for you today
the fed plans to ban
policy makers
from owning individual stocks and this
is an issue we've been talking about for
a long time the personal financial
interests of members of congress
number two
ron desantis radical trumpian florida
republican governor governor of florida
and florida which makes it even crazier
he's going to give five grand signing
bonus or wants to to unvaccinated police
that are quitting other police
departments in other states to come be
cops in florida
okay
and then lastly
texas lieutenant governor dan patrick
who offered to start handing out rewards
for people who find voter fraud he has
finally paid out his first reward to a
democrat
for identifying identifying voter fraud
carried out by
a republican
you've you love to see it you really
love to see it all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show
uh sign up at
joinpackman.com you've got to spell it
correctly i get emails sometimes from
people who say david
your membership website has a virus
if you spell my name wrong it will take
you to a different website that i don't
know what's on it okay
join pacman p-a-k-m-a-n.com
sign up coupon code
felony21 the code is such a big discount
it should be a felony but it's legal
okay felony 21 is the coupon code
sign up at joinpakman.com
and we'll see you on today's bonus
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman